Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Perhaps the big question which seems to follow the bigger question of are there
others out there in the universe is if so,
what are they like the discovery and study of not just extraterrestrial life,
but an extraterrestrial civilization would be one of the greatest moments in
human history.
We have a great interest in understanding such things,
not just how aliens would look or what they're made of,
but how they might think what their culture,
philosophies,
values,
politics is silo,
organization,
technology and science.
The progression of those fields,
history,
et Cetera,
are if they even view those things in a similar way that we do such a study
would just be inherently extremely interesting.
But of course furthermore,
it would provide a very important insight into ourselves to truly understand
that uniqueness and intricacy,
that human intelligence,
perhaps it has to be compared to a non human intelligence due to the great
likelihood that unless the Youtube clickbait conspiracies are actually
substantial alien civilizations are likely light years from us.
For the moment.
We are only guessing at these things,
but our understanding of science has grown and we're left to use logic to make
those guesses educated,
which is an important step in science in this video.
By examining the mini courses evolution has taken on our planet,
discussing known conditions on other worlds considered to be potentially
habitable,
and by attempting to analyze our civilization as objectively as possible,
we can form some pretty reasonable hypotheses about what these aliens might be
like after all,
and we'll create a few fictional worlds to fit these aliens into to get a better
picture of the dynamic in which they might exist.
So let's get to it.
Let's weed out some unlikelihood here.
First,
aliens are Asya Phi favorite for obvious reasons.
They've been depicted in a number of ways on a big spectrum from unrecognizable
monsters to just humans with wrinkly noses.
Contrary to 95% of the races on shows and movies like star Trek and star wars.
Aliens will most certainly not look like awkward humans mixing like Spock's
human mother and alien father did is basically almost certainly an impossibility
and probably not an attractive prospect anyway.
And most of all they will not be speaking American English their very first day
if they even talk at all.
So cross out weird versions of earth regarding alien civilizations.
Any beings we encounter will likely to be significantly different from us.
How different though?
Well,
they have any recognizable features.
Some astrobiologists say no.
Any aliens we encounter will be entirely different from us with no shared
features like eyes by Pete Elysium hands,
et cetera.
I unlike those astrobiologist have not forgotten though that convergent
evolution as a thing.
Humans,
of course,
look the way we look at the way we act,
think the way we think,
et Cetera,
because of very specific line of evolution,
not just our hominid or primate ancestors,
but our broader mammal and and long before that had traits that stuck with us
that might evolve differently on other worlds,
especially if the conditions on that world a greatly different take human eyes,
for example,
our eyes and those are,
most of our mammo relatives are attuned to the light that they are the visible
spectrum because it was beneficial to our ancestor survival.
Not all animals on our planet see the same way though.
Bees for example,
see ultraviolet radiation and snakes and infrared,
it's likely that most aliens,
if they can see,
may see the world somewhat differently than we do,
especially if they're an environmental conditions are very much different.
I do think that most aliens will be able to see though,
and I'll get back to why I think that as a case later.
For now,
let's take a fictional world that we'll call novus orbiting a red dwarf star.
Red Dwarf Stars constitute about 85% of the stars in our galaxy and make up to
50 of the 60 closest stars to us.
They're quiet and they live a long time,
much longer than our stars,
opposed to live,
possibly trillions of years.
Given these circumstances,
we might one day meet someone from a plant around such a nice little star.
Novus isn't a planet though.
It's a moon and you plan it around.
This star has a reduced,
nope.
Still completely possible chance of developing life being what is called tidally
locked.
This means that one side of the planet faces a star at all times.
A planet around such a star would have one side of the planet baked constantly
in heat,
likely uninhabitable.
Most organisms,
as we understand them,
the other side and less heat from the hot side makes its way to the cold side.
Maybe too cold.
This would restrict life to a ring around a planet in which a star is
impermanent twilight,
but Novus,
which orbits?
It's gas giant.
Once every five days has a day.
Night cycle does fixing this issue.
Novus is also rocky has two great oceans,
polls,
et Cetera,
but that doesn't mean it's just like home.
The atmosphere is somewhat different than the arresting.
The gravity is only 70% that Everest,
but the atmospheric pressure is about the same.
The days and nights are of course longer and the sky is red and in the day with
a host star,
it's dimmer here and accordingly the plant life is thick and black.
How would an alien civilization evolve here?
Well,
for starters,
it would probably see in infrared vision our visible spectrum not being ideal
for surviving on this kind of world.
Having a thicker atmosphere and lower gravity organisms here could not only get
bigger than on earth,
but in fact have a much easier time flying,
which is exactly what the intelligent aliens on the brink of civilization here
are capable of doing.
Their ancestors lived in colonies and the trees being pack hunters,
but they're rapidly changing conditions on their world has caused them to come
down to the ground developing,
walking legs.
Those still supporting themselves as well.
With the large wings condition has changed because of the orbit around Novus.
Parent plant around its star for part of its orbit.
It exists within the stars habitable zone,
but then it swings out slightly past it.
Winter on this world becomes unbearably cold and the aliens here must evolve to
be able to handle it.
Much of their time away from the colonies are still spent in flight.
They've gotten longer and more flexible.
A clause and his legs,
however,
still remain as sharp as ever from the days of their ancestors,
but are more precise now allowing them to grip things more firmly and precisely
a trait which has come in handy as they began to experiment with things like
fire and tools well began with dropping blunt rocks and unsuspecting prey from
above has evolved to dropping crudely sharpened rocks and much more effective
method which could evolve into spheres.
They are strictly carnivorous.
They have snouts with razor sharp teeth.
They communicate with a large number of noises,
a combination of different kinds of what sounds like complicated wolf barking
mixed with flooding their tails.
It's not get as complex as what we call a language on earth.
The more complex than anything else we've observed on this planet.
Accordingly,
if they had a name for the land or themselves,
we wouldn't quite be able to pronounce it and accordingly,
the name Novus sticks.
Still though these noises don't constitute all of their communication,
especially in a mid flight hunt with a prey has evolved at Dotta.
Tara from above gestures and even visible changes in their wings are important
parts of relaying information,
blood rushes through the wings and distinct patterns.
When one of these aliens abuse potential food causing a visible riots and heat
and signaling to the rest of the group to follow said aliens move other patterns
and variations in the wing signal.
Other things,
fatigue,
aggression,
sadness,
happiness,
fear,
sexual interest.
We may struggle to recognize these emotions should we view them as there may
only be my new differences between the wide range of emotions,
which is aliens wish to convey,
but they would likely come as naturally to these aliens as facial expressions do
to us.
When a member of this racist shows aggression.
Another may in turn naturally show aggression and defense,
but more importantly when a member of a species is placed sadness,
another may in turn also display sadness.
These aliens have evolved the ability of empathy to relate to one another and
exchange their thoughts.
The males hunt down the parameters of the colonies if feed the females and the
offspring,
they hunt in a long night and rest and eat their kill and the long days.
Hierarchy is important here and the Alpha male and female and their offspring
eat first and progressively the rest eat as well.
Partners here,
mate,
for life monogamy evolved and these organisms as to became more intelligent and
their brains required longer to grow the eggs.
They're primitive ancestors laid became more complicated sex which had to be
guarded for several earth months and the offspring then took several earth years
to reach adulthood.
Monogamy also helps stave off the remnants of violence,
sexually transmitted disease which has been ravaging their continent and killing
many.
This all sounds like quite a bit of imagination,
but there are may scientific and logical reasons for these traits and the aliens
of Novus.
Remember that convergent evolution thing I mentioned?
Convergence.
Evolution is essentially were to essentially unrelated organisms evolve the same
physical traits because of pressures from their environment on earth.
Birds,
bats and butterflies evolve the wings independently of each other because it was
useful and they're given environments.
Why am I so sure that most aliens will have,
for example,
some kind of eyes because of how useful they are.
They evolved on earth over 500 million ago and have since evolved independently,
independently around 50 to a hundred times,
restart life on earth,
change the direction of a bit,
come back in 500 million years,
whatever animal life is here,
we'll have eyes again,
not all eyes are the same and the aliens of Novus here seed very differently
than we do,
but there's an obvious evolutionary pressure in such a world to develop eyes.
Some animal life on earth and caves and the deep sea are essentially blind,
but it is not the norm in such.
Life is at a disadvantage in environments with light and the same would hold
true on similar worlds.
Why do these organisms fly?
Well,
it's not necessary.
It was just a fictional addition to explore new concept,
but some alien races in the universe may indeed have wings.
More importantly though,
these aliens are social hunters.
Why is that important?
Well,
looking again at life on earth,
the smartest organisms are the ones which broadly have to figure things out.
Many of the intelligent animals on earth such as raccoons,
whales,
birds of prey,
dogs,
et Cetera,
are hunters or more often omnivores,
including us,
the equivalent of a deer on the moon.
Novus just has to know how to eat,
reproduce,
and run away,
and if it does fairly well for itself.
The hunter,
however,
has to be able to track it,
predict its movements,
coordinate with other members of the pack.
There was an evolutionary pressure to be more cunning.
Generally a Predator doesn't have to be a genius,
but as I mentioned,
this moon has a rapidly changing environment because its host planet has an
eccentric orbit similar to Africa or run the dawn of mankind or the ice age.
Later on in human history,
hunting in conditions which are constantly changing requires even more
intelligence and more factors thrown into the game.
The sharper you have to be and like our ancestors,
these aliens are subject to those wild factors.
Being social,
as I mentioned,
is an important aspect to these aliens are working together for a mutual goal of
us developing a bond between each other and a mentality for cooperation.
They are for the more developing the ability to communicate thoughts and
feelings with each other.
This greatly enhances their ability to work together and succeed and also
depends upon a higher intelligence.
As their intelligence grows,
they're able to not only find new ways to find food,
but communicate those ideas to the rest of the group relatively quickly.
However,
being carnivores,
they are rather naturally aggressive for the more as they operate within a
hierarchy.
We're an Alpha male and female.
Typically not only the most fit,
but also the best hundreds of the group get the most food and have the best odds
of reproducing successfully.
There is great pressure within the colonies to be dominant.
This leads to fights,
especially among males and with unpredictable quantities of resources,
fights between colonies over hunting turf.
These aliens are not afraid to use their tools and such in these fights,
which should they progress into entire societies could leave to an equivalent of
war,
which in the end may threaten their own very survival,
their evolution to objects as crucial as well.
Their claws of evolves from crude killing tools to precise instruments while
supporting themselves with their powerful wings.
They may use their claws in a similar fashion that we use our hands.
So to summarize the aliens of the Moon,
Novus here,
there are important differences but important similarities.
The organisms here as will be the case with any organism you encounter anywhere
in its original form has evolved to fit within its environment.
If he wants to find the major differences between us and them,
look at the important differences in our environments.
Both earth and Novus are rocky warm water.
We roles with evolution,
which followed a similar path,
microorganisms which evolved in the photosynthetic organisms as well as animal
life,
which consumes those photosynthetic organisms and indeed hunters which consume
those organisms and perhaps hunters on top of those.
Hunters are the case on both worlds.
Such ecosystems,
though they may be very complex,
may be the norm on earth like worlds,
but they're star is dimmer or red dwarf unless they see a different kind of
light,
much more effective for hunting,
especially during long nights there gravity is lower and the atmosphere is
proportionately thicker than ours making flight a much easier exercise.
We can go on talking about potential differences that might arise in an infinite
number of circumstances,
but what is,
what's important to highlight is as similarities,
which may be consistent among civilized intelligences or at least common.
The first hypothesis is that many intelligent extraterrestrials will be
omnivores or at least carnivores.
Impossibly we'll have had ancestors who lived in rapidly changing environments.
It's through this that nature seems to put pressure on organisms to develop
higher intelligence.
Secondly,
aliens across the universe may develop somewhat similar structures for survival,
not just eyes,
but I hope it can be inferred that many other structures come on on earth may be
common among extra tress as well.
They may not have all the sensory organs we have and may in fact have some that
we lack their sensory organs much like ours will probably be close to their
brain and all groups close by so that an organism may see smell and taste their
food all at once.
Will they have,
for example,
stereoscopic vision as the majority are probably carnivores or Omnivores,
that is likely the case.
Stereoscopic vision will be required for tool use later on when civilization
actually arises.
Will they hear in the same range as us?
Probably not exactly though.
Possibly similarly,
whether they have teeth,
some may,
some may not.
Teeth seem to be very commonplace in useful.
Her many animals.
What about the body structure of animals?
Well,
whereby pedal,
which is Latin for two feet for two of course,
how we walk and by bronchial which means two arms.
Most animals are not quite structured like that,
but most do have four limbs and manipulate their environment with their front or
upper extremities.
The ones of course,
in their visual range,
it's possible that other aliens will be head,
shoulders,
arms,
torso,
legs,
feet.
In a similar fashion that we are,
but I wouldn't bet on it being the norm.
The aliens of Novus,
for example,
like birds are technically bipeds even though most of their long range moving is
done through flight.
However,
they are capable of supporting themselves what their wings and manipulating
their environment with their rear extremities.
Well,
they have exoskeletons or endoskeletons organisms with endoskeletons like us are
the norm in larger intelligent animals,
but that may not be consistently the case.
How many limbs were the aliens?
Have?
Forests seems to work just fine for animals and in fact,
adding on legs or arms may make things more difficult for larger organisms.
Evolution has consistently selected organisms with four limbs.
Will they be Endothermic,
Aka warm blooded?
Probably warm blooded animals require more food and therefore have to be smarter
to find it.
Furthermore,
complex brains do better in constant temperature.
Importantly,
however,
aliens are set up because of the great prevalence of symmetry in nature.
Probably all intelligent extra terrestrials will be symmetrical.
How will they reproduce?
Live bearing as we do may not be the norm.
Asexual production,
however,
it is not likely sexual reproduction in the genetic variation that accompanies
it is very likely to be more beneficial than asexual reproduction in such
organisms.
Accordingly,
to avoid excessive complexity to core ism or the existence of male and female is
probably the most commonplace.
Will they breathe oxygen very possibly earth life.
Then it become more complex until there was sufficient oxygen in the atmosphere.
It's crucial for the metabolism of organisms like us and anaerobic organisms
don't become nearly as diverse as oxygen and breathers.
Well,
they bleed likely complex aliens will requires blood or some similar system to
carry oxygen to their body and such well that blood be red if they're indeed
breathing oxygen.
Probably copper has been suggested as an alternative to the iron that makes our
blood red and carries oxygen making blood green,
but it isn't as efficient and on an even deeper level will they use DNA?
Very likely.
Something like it.
Complex organisms don't just assemble themselves.
We will most likely see alternatives to some of the things that we weren't
expecting.
But my point in all of this is to hypothesizes structures that we see evolve
independently,
over and over and be successful on earth in a wide variety of environments
probably evolve on most earthlike worlds as well.
Although keep in mind,
perhaps not every civilization comes from an earthlight world.
I don't mean to suggest that nowhere in the entire university of things get
unrecognizably weird.
Rather,
I'm saying that we can make educated guesses about the average.
I had referenced the Cambrian explosion to support this.
The Cambrian explosion was a period in early Earth's history in which a very
great variety of organisms evolve.
There were some very weird looking organisms like this OPA Binya or this anomaly
cars with time,
the variety decrease as a structures that were inferior got weeded out by those
which worked the best.
The structures that work the best of course worked because they fit their
respective environments and alien environments will be different,
but we will only see drastic differences in drastically different environments.
And I would guess that the basic conditions on earth might be around average for
worlds that produced extraterrestrial intelligences.
Anyway.
Thirdly,
alien civilizations were likely be social in the sense that they both work
together,
communicate somehow,
not necessarily social in the sense that we are.
They may be very different,
much more different than we can imagine,
but cooperation and exchange of ideas are crucial to what we consider to be
civilization.
Solitary hunters,
perhaps even species in which males instinctively kill other males from mating
rights probably cannot develop civilization as we understand it.
How will aliens communicate?
Very likely every way possible.
Humans use verbal language,
sign language and body language,
et Cetera,
to communicate other animals on this planet.
He's a variety of ways.
He naked as well.
Things may be even more diverse among intelligent extra terrestrials throughout
the universe.
Fourth,
they will need to be able to manipulate tools,
not necessarily right off the bat.
Humans only gradually evolved the ability to manipulate our environments with
greater precision,
but taking a shark or a tiger or an elephant,
even if they possess civilization building intelligence,
they couldn't operate tools very well.
It would be outside of their physical limitations and their intelligence would
be mostly used to endure and their normal primitive lifestyles.
Does that mean hands?
Not necessarily.
Our hands work very well to get whatever job done or at least construct
something that can get the job done.
And indeed the aliens of Novus,
you'll see have clause which had begun evolving to work with tools,
but other forms of manipulating environments may indeed be possible.
So we've established those four hypotheses and we will of course review the mall
at the end of the video for now.
Let's move on.
As we leave this world to visit our next,
we noticed something peculiar each morning.
The members of the group pile rocks to the east of their colony where the star
rises each morning when it begins to set in the evening.
And of course,
remember one day on his planet lasts as long as a few on earth.
The individuals fly to pile rocks west of there.
Connie,
this ritual seems to serve no purpose and may be a purely cultural or religious
practice.
For the more individuals at the colony who have died.
Here are not left alone.
Much of the colony when a death occurs,
flies with the individuals chosen to carry the corpse over.
Large body of water with a corpse is dropped in from above.
Again,
serving no survival purposes seeming to be a form of a funeral.
One might wonder what they think of their world,
whether they believe the Red Sun,
the guests giant,
the stars in the sky are,
or maybe if they even follow up.
Primitive religions similar to the ones of early earth.
If a culture is passed along to their children the same way,
practical survival knowledges and possibly if they are capable of thinking of
abstractions,
predicting the biological structures of extra terrestrials isn't easy.
We may be wrong about a lot,
but we can use organisms on our planet and the courses of evolution that they
have taken to predict quite a bit about extraterrestrial evolution.
Simply start with an earthlight world in a number of variables and subsequently
come up with solutions to those differences.
It's easier to make conjectures about biology and then culture.
Though we don't have any other examples of culture other than what has been
created from our own human experience and human minds.
We have the behavior of other animals it take and play with and consider how bad
behavior may manifest itself as culture or a society should.
Greater intelligence arise and intelligent social animals on earth,
especially many social animals have hierarchies and compete for dominance in for
food rights and reproduction rights and some animals like elephants even mourn
their dead or act selflessly for the betterment of the group,
especially for the young.
Many animals are scared of things which they do not understand but can be
observed curiously investigating these things.
Nevertheless,
my dog,
for example,
is scared of my guitar,
but if I set it down,
he goes over and very hesitantly checks it out.
This suggests that curiosity runs in many intelligent or somewhat intelligent
species.
It just manifests itself in a very complex way in humans and these things may
hold true for other extra terrestrials as well.
Here,
for example,
the aliens of Novus are clearly moving the rocks from east to west following a
path of their son.
Perhaps out of respect,
perhaps out of fear,
but the fact that they have a ritual around a naturally occurring event,
which doesn't seem to aid their survival as evidence that they have as questions
about their environment and that they are curious that they have a solution for
those questions suggest that they can generate abstractions in their mind.
The fact they have a sort of burial ritual suggests that they mourn their dead.
They feel empathy,
which we know as well because of their wing patterns and death and a questions
they likely ask about it as curious animals,
mainly the culture,
tradition,
society,
et Cetera.
Trying to define alien culture is essentially asking yourself a thing from a
perspective that is not your own but about which you know nothing in an
environment in which you know nothing as well.
Even for the most creative,
it is a very difficult task.
As I said earlier on in this video,
we lack an example of what is intelligent but not human for comparison.
So it is difficult to be sure what traits,
ideas,
philosophy,
culture,
et cetera.
Guarding intelligent species are specific to humans or commonplace among
intelligent beings.
One day,
perhaps these aliens will learn to master things like animal husbandry by taking
control the populations of animals they currently hunt.
The aliens of Novus may build more complicated structures when they come to
process more complicated language.
They may go from rocks to spears to beyond.
One day we may meet such an alien race,
but for now this theoretical race is to be left for a new world.
Let's visit a world known as Panthalassa.
Panthalassa is a world which orbits a star of much like our son and is
relatively the same size as earth with similar gravity.
Just to make this example of straight forward,
the big difference is that the whole planet is covered in water.
Not a single island is to be found anywhere on this planet.
Such planets called Ocean planets or water worlds are believed to exist being
somewhat common among habitable worlds.
It's not so outrageous remembering how common water is in the universe and how
three fourths of our planet on the surface as water within the great oceans of
Penta Lasa exists a peculiar species and intelligent species that looks somewhat
like an octopus,
but with four appendages.
So if you'd like,
you may call it quadruples.
These 10 schools are very thick and powerful and assistant quadruple.
I'm moving quickly throughout the water.
The quadro pie meet all the criteria we listed on Novis.
Their environment isn't accessibly turbulent,
but they are extremely omnivorous finding food and seemingly unlikely places.
They have no ability to hear,
but they have a very acute sense of smell and are capable of seeing a huge
amount of colors in a visible light spectrum.
Odd considering they spend perhaps half of the time,
the deeper,
darker areas of the sea at that we reached the third point.
These organisms communicate with elaborate,
changing patterns of colors on a tentacles very precisely coordinated
bioluminescent patterns resembling the complexity of human language.
While these organisms could simply consume the variety of photosynthetic
organisms on the surface of the planet,
it is not the preferred meal and it's much more worthwhile hunting.
The variety of organisms that live in the ocean.
This species stays together and packs from mutual defense and survival.
The females carry the young for the equivalent of six earth months,
but the species is frequently on a move making gestation difficult.
They're a skilled hunters coordinating attacks.
It confuse and enclose upon prey in the place of hands,
which we and our alien friends on Novis use.
They have tentacles,
which in time could evolve to manipulate their environment to build tools and
such things,
but what environment?
The planet is a giant ocean.
The solid surface is miles beneath endless water and down on the bottom where
one finally reaches a solid surface,
the pressure is perhaps unbearably great,
so great that water may condense into ice called ice seven not as a result of
temperature,
but as I said,
extreme pressure,
forcing the water molecules into a solid only ocean like organisms and perhaps
the organism to the sky inhabit this world.
Neither have the materials needed to get civilization.
As we understand that going and even if it did metallurgy,
electronics,
and many other things which we take for granted are impossible underwater.
The quadro pods of pound philoso serve to bring us to our fifth hypothesis are
closely related.
Fourth hypothesis was that aliens needed to have the,
the ability to manipulate their environment.
Our fifth is that intelligent extraterrestrial must have an environment to
manipulate in the first place.
Organisms which exist in the clouds of gas giants or in great endless oceans
like 10th Alessa may evolve intelligence,
but their environments aren't suitable to build civilization for that.
One would like to,
if need lands as on earth accordingly,
the quadro pause main dear as primitive hunters indefinitely,
definitely despite their intellectual capabilities.
So let's move on.
Thus far we've been rather superficial.
We've discussed aliens in their environments,
but to really get to know a living organism,
you have to know them deep down what makes them up.
What about their environment is crucial to their existence.
Biologists are agreed on three fundamental requisites.
Life requires an energy source.
Essential building blocks I he chemicals.
And a liquid solvent for proper comparison.
Let's ask,
what are those things for earth life for you?
Well,
the energy source for humans and most earth life is of course the sun.
The Sun is of course at the center of the food chain.
I'm hoping you recall photosynthesis and such things from biology.
However,
not all are life is dependent on the sun.
There are organisms and the deep sea which utilize hydrothermal vents.
If the sun were to disappear,
they might not notice at all.
Such organisms providing courage meant for the possibility of life on a world
like Europa.
However,
not as much for civilization.
Remember the unlikelihood of deep seas civilizations that we just discussed,
these key metrics and then a deep sea are fine,
but all known intelligent animals on earth are dependent on the sun directly and
indirectly and it's hard to imagine many more suitable energy sources.
Accordingly,
the majority of intelligent aliens will likely have evolved on a rocky world,
an ecosystem dependent on its host star,
I would say within the habitable zone,
the region around the star in which earthlike planets could support liquid water
on their surface.
But that brings me to my next question here on earth.
The ingredients that make you up are pretty well understood.
You are a carbon based life form.
Many,
much of your makeup consists of carbon compounds.
You need oxygen,
hydrogen,
nitrogen,
calcium,
phosphorous,
potassium,
sulfur,
sodium chloride,
magnesium,
iron,
and some of the chemicals as well.
All of these ingredients come together in our solvent,
water,
every living thing on earth as a carbon based life form in this manner and every
single one requires water.
But are we sure that carbon based life forms and water are the only ways life
may have dealt in the universe?
It is in fact unclear a popular alternative to carbon.
It's silicon,
but scientists aren't so willing to accept many alternatives.
Carbon has common 10 times more common in silicon.
It's flexible,
it's versatile,
it forms a wider variety of bonds.
Silicon forms,
bonds with organic molecules as well,
but the bonds are not as diverse or stable as those with carbon,
other alternatives or even less promising than carbon.
If you know your cell biology,
you know just how intricate and complicated life and it's tiny as levels can be.
Those million and a half functions with their esoteric names require
versatility.
So silicon life forms or by foam is made of any other billing box may exist,
but they're likely not common.
There likely very outnumbered by carbon based life forms as carbon,
very much outnumbered silicon and the universe with regard to alien
civilizations of likelihood is that anyone we meet would be carbon based or had
origins in carbon.
What about water?
Water has a similar story.
It's a very common throughout the universe and it's very good at what it does.
Like carbon,
we can conclude right off the bath of the most intelligent aliens we meet.
We require just as we do,
but of course alternatives have been proposed and hypothetical life forms that
don't require water are somewhat more attractive to the non carbon based life
forms.
Scientists have suggested ammonia hydrocarbons such as methane and ethane,
hydrogen fluoride,
sulfuric acid,
liquid nitrogen as well as others as replacements.
But what's so great about water besides being commonplace?
Well.
The polarity of water allows it to dissolve more chemicals than any other
liquid,
even the strongest acids on our planet,
just not as violently.
Of course.
Furthermore,
water has some important properties.
It has a high heat capacity and has the uncommon trait of being less den to the
solid in the liquid,
which I'm sure you've noticed if you've ever put ice in your drink.
Why does that matter?
Because of bodies of water were to freeze solid.
With the inverse being the case,
they'd freeze bottom up being much more destructive to forming.
Life below water is common place,
but of course worlds with bodies of other liquids,
siblings this throughout the universe.
In fact,
you can see one with a telescope.
Titan,
Saturn's largest moon is such a world that has lakes of hydrocarbons,
I,
methane and ethane on its surface with an average temperature of negative 180
degrees Celsius.
That's far too cold for any water loving organisms,
but for just right for organisms utilizing the hydrocarbons at a solvent.
Perhaps if we revisit tightened,
we'll find organisms on its surface and the lakes.
But in our brief look at Titan when we visited the plant,
we didn't find grandiose life forms that we'd expect with intelligent life.
No one contacted earth and told us to come get our Huygens probe author lawn.
So in summary,
organisms throughout the universe,
possibly even intelligent life may be built from many different kinds of things
about the commonality in effectiveness of water and carbon suggested the most
intelligent aliens we will find will be built with considerable similarity to
us.
Other factors of course include gravity not being excessively weaker than the
earth or accessibly strong.
The planet will probably require a magnetic field as well.
Otherwise,
the ingredients that would have made worlds like Venus and Mars habitable will
be stripped away by their host stars.
But could this magnetic field be too strong?
Remember that evolution occurs by mistakes being made when DNA copies itself
caused largely by solar radiation.
And of course we have to consider other factors as well.
Remember that we might've had more extinctions on earth,
if not for a big brother Jupiter collecting space to breathe that would've
otherwise hit us.
And remember how fortunate we are to live where we do.
And the galaxy closer to the center of the galaxy where there is much more going
on.
The evolution of life may have been hindered by supernova and black holes and
such.
So we've outlined a good number of basic requisites and likelihoods.
And despite the complexity,
we have some solid hypotheses we're not done yet.
Though there are more factors to consider,
more possibilities for review,
considering how aliens may turn out and what kind of circumstances we can
predict a find.
But for now,
let's actually calculate just how many civilizations might exist in the Milky
Way galaxy at this point in time.
Such a prediction might sound like it rests upon a relatively weak foundation.
There's not a lot that we know about the universe to make such a prediction.
And quite frankly,
the answer could be as high as a billion and as low as one us.
Well,
yes,
there is a lot that we don't know that we have a significant amount of knowledge
of it.
Can you use to at least make a good hypothesis?
We're not just pulling numbers out of the air.
There's actually an equation for it.
The Drake equation,
the Drake equation works like this.
You start with the rate of star formation and the Milky Way galaxy or as Carl
Sagan did it and as we will do for the purposes of this video,
the amount of stars currently in our Milky Way Galaxy represented by n sub star.
Multiply that by the fraction of stars that have planets and moons,
F sub p then the number of planets and sizable moons around each star which are
ecologically suitable for life and sub e the fraction of those worlds which
actually do develop life apps of l the number of worlds I'm which intelligent
life arises from those lifeforms f sub I,
the number of worlds on which civilizations arise from that intelligence f sub c
and the number of those civilizations which have not yet died out by self
destruction.
F Sub d.
You can do this yourself,
multiplied those together to get n the number of civilizations which may
currently exist in the Milky Way galaxy.
Keep in mind,
this is just one way of doing it as a model isn't the most common way in.
There are a number of other factors suggested to be included in all forms are
nothing more than educated guesswork,
but for now it'll do so end sub star.
How many stars are in our galaxy that we do know?
Roughly the lowest estimate is a 100 billion.
The highest estimate is 400 billion.
The standard modern estimate is 200 billion,
so we'll go with that.
How many of those stars have planets?
Well,
modern science actually shows that planets are plentiful throughout the galaxy.
Perhaps most stars have planets.
And furthermore,
the discovery that binary systems can host planets as well only adds onto this
will be conservative and say about half of all stars in the galaxy have planets.
So of the hundred billion stars with planets,
how many habitable worlds are there around the each star on average?
If you've seen my life on other worlds series,
you probably know that there are 10 or 11 worlds including the earth,
which could be considered to have life on them.
That's the highest estimate though the atmospheres of Jupiter and Venus and the
hydrocarbon lakes of Titan are included in that estimate and all except for
those and for Mars and earth refer to life in subsurface ocean is which may or
may not possible.
Furthermore,
we may have an unusually high prevalence of such worlds,
but then modern estimates are so bold as to predict that one out of six stars in
the galaxy hasn't earthlight world around it.
So we'll just say on average one suitable world around each star.
So there are about a hundred billion worlds in our galaxy,
which we would be interested in taking a look at to look for life.
How often though there's life actually arise on those worlds.
Well,
I don't see why life wouldn't arise in a world which we considered to be
suitable for life,
life or rosemary quickly on our world and stuck.
It seems unnecessary to ask,
but it takes into account that we aren't aware of certain conditions necessary
to start life,
so it will say only on 80% of world's on which we expect to find in life.
Does life actually arrives?
That still leaves 80 billion inhabited worlds in our galaxy alone,
which has quite a number,
but now those numbers get cut down on how many worlds does life evolved to be so
complex that it actually gives a rise to intelligence?
Well,
on our planet,
it took over three and a half billion years of microbial life for complex life
to evolve into multicellular organisms,
and our planet has some very suitable conditions.
Probably the majority,
the vast majority of those 80 billion worlds are home to nothing more complex
than bacteria.
Beyond that,
and the 500 million years or so of multicellular organisms,
there has been only one species in that entire time span,
which has evolved to our level of intelligence.
Obviously us,
there are other smart animals like chimpanzees,
dolphins,
raccoons,
but they're not exactly on the path to civilization and there's no evidence to
think that they would be among inhabited worlds.
Earth,
leg worlds are probably the minority among earthlike worlds.
Complex life might not evolve quite so often,
and among that complex life,
intelligence might in fact be very rare,
so it will take a very low estimate.
0.0001% of inhabited worlds actually develop intelligent beings capable of
developing civilization.
That brings us to 8 million.
Now this next one is in reference to the eighth and ninth hypothetical rules
I've listed here.
How many of those intelligent beings actually developed civilization?
Well,
probably the circumstances which put pressure for intelligence to develop our
common on worlds on which intelligence can actually evolve into something.
Gas Giants and water worlds with intelligent beings may be rare to begin with
because there's no pressure to be a big brain.
Furthermore,
not all intelligent beings might be capable of building civilization and perhaps
not all intelligence manifests itself in the way that ours does to where
intelligent beings or at least beings we would consider intelligent,
don't create what we consider socialization,
so we'll say half the time and that might be a low estimate.
Intelligent beings actually build a civilization that leaves us with 4 million
civilizations.
That's a huge number.
Now for the final variable here,
how many of those civilizations destroy themselves before they really begin to
move out and communicate for long periods of time?
That's very unpredictable.
We don't know exactly how alien minds work regarding their technologies,
war,
power,
politics,
et cetera.
Some may be more ridiculous than us.
Some may be more level headed.
It's hard to say it,
but for now we'll say about half of all civilizations destroy themselves with a
war or misuse technology or something of that nature.
Aggressiveness,
the desire for power and the willingness to kill a present in many animal
species on earth and are found even of course in our own species far too
regularly,
it's probably the case among other intelligent beings as well,
especially as they have likely evolved from omnivorous or carnivores social
units.
That brings us with these estimates to 2 million civilizations out there and the
Milky Way alone,
which have already evolved or are on their way to be evolving.
Maybe these estimates seem pretty high to you.
If you disagree with me on one of these points,
we can even lower it to 200,000 that's still a lot of civilizations out there.
Do you see a problem with that though?
Why do these civilizations have had a head start of a couple billion years
before us?
By now at least,
some should be extremely advanced,
but regardless,
we have zero evidence of any activity outside of our solar system.
No Dyson's spheres,
no radio signals,
not even an accidental text message.
The apparent likelihood of an abundance of civilizations mixed with the apparent
of lack of any evidence for them throughout all of history is called the Fermi
paradox.
Astrobiologist who share this concern have laid out a number of reasons for
this.
The first intelligent civilization building life or even multicellular,
animalistic life is rare.
I agreed.
I gave the rise of intelligence.
I'm very low estimate of my equation,
but perhaps it's even rarer than that.
Perhaps most life harboring worlds and about the course of their evolution
without ever evolving intelligence.
Perhaps there are very few,
or we are among the first to have this rare gift,
so of course it's silent.
The second life itself is very rare.
We're not entirely sure how life began on earth.
We have yet to recreate the process,
so perhaps there's something very crucial we're missing about how life
originates.
That lowers his prediction drastically.
Number three,
alien intelligence evolves at a somewhat predicted rate,
but the problem rests in the sub destruction variable.
Intelligent civilizations,
as I said,
it probably evolved from aggressive animals.
The hunters,
carnivores and Omnivores,
many that are social,
maybe very hierarchal,
as many social animals on earth,
our nuclear war,
genetic engineering gone wrong.
Things of that nature may be an inevitability for the great majority of
civilizations they can't escape from,
which eventually leads to their doom.
Number four,
the vastness of space is too great for us to have heard anything.
Civilizations may indeed be out there,
possibly plentiful,
but they're so far apart.
The contact is actually rare and possibly there is some sort of problem with
interstellar space travel that we're just missing.
We are,
after all,
just beginning to deal with that.
These are all worth considering,
but keep in mind,
1 billion years ago,
if there were only just one single civilization around in the galaxy that beat
these odds by now,
they would have been capable.
If they followed the line of progression we'd expect of having dominated the
whole galaxy by now.
These hypotheses are worth considering,
but they're not my personal favorites for that reason.
Thankfully there are many other factors to consider too.
Five aliens are just too alien.
I didn't give a specific scenario,
but I've discussed this video how intelligent aliens might think so differently
from us so they don't go on to develop civilization.
As we understand that we might all be very different from each other.
Much of what we are as humans,
our curiosity and desire for contact and to understand ourselves and things like
that are genetically evolved traits,
which not all aliens might express or share in the same way.
Of course,
some aliens would want to talk,
but it's worth considering that there are some who don't want to talk,
some who are Zena phobic and afraid to talk and some who wouldn't understand or
even notice one of our messages and vice versa.
Even if they did talk,
we often underestimate just how different aliens might be.
Number six,
they're not communicating using our means of communication anymore compared to
their level of technology.
Our technology may have looked at them.
How homo erectus sharpening rocks looks to us.
The idea that they would still be communicating as we do across interstellar
space at that may be a bit far fetched.
Number seven,
surely someone would have heard something that we've sent though it's dubious
that everyone everywhere gives up entirely on radio signals,
especially knowing that they use them in the past.
So this brings me to something which I consider it to be very likely,
often commonly called the zoo hypothesis.
Not that earth is one giant zoo for super advanced aliens to secretly visit.
It's possible,
but this refers more to something like the prime directive on Star Trek.
Aliens may be fully aware of our existence,
then may know all about us,
but they may a be waiting for us to meet certain technological,
social,
ethical,
political,
whatever criteria before they contact us so that they don't disrupt the natural
progression of our civilization.
Or B,
there's so advanced that they don't care about us to an ancient,
powerful civilization that has traversed the galaxy.
Earth may not be the most interesting thing to them and they may view us how we
view ants.
These are all excellent hypotheses,
but I myself tend to lean towards the last two,
which I mentioned though.
For some reason many scientists did not.
Most scientists,
popular scientists I believe,
haven't really examined the depth of the question though,
and I would even say that most scientists are probably wrong about aliens in
this regard and that there is an obvious answer to the Fermi paradox.
It is not discussed nearly enough as it should be.
It goes in line with the last hypothesis there,
but it goes beyond that.
I wouldn't make a claim that sounds as arrogant as that without a rationale
behind it.
It isn't as arrogant as it seems.
It's actually an admission of humility.
I am under the impression that we're bragging about how we think aliens progress
right now.
A very common tool in this field that we use is something called the Carter Chef
scale.
It ranks civilizations from type zero type one to type two to type three and
even in some circumstances beyond that to type four and type five a type one
civilization has mastery over its entire planet or a moon.
It can control the weather,
it can prevent earthquakes,
it can harness all of the energy that it's home planet provides.
Type two civilizations have mastery over their entire solar system.
Type three have mastery over an entire galaxy.
I typed for a civilization has mastery over the entire universe and a type five
civilization mastery over large areas of or the entire multi-verse,
which is a lot of power.
It's generally accepted that civilizations progressed to these ranks over the,
over the course of thousands,
then millions,
then maybe billions of years slowly evolving.
I see a problem with a cutter chef scale though.
My problem with the Kardashian scale is that it's predicting the societal
evolution of aliens about whom we know nothing to begin with at rates of
technology billions of years ahead of us.
I can't help but refer back to the fact that people in the year 1900 who are
asked to predict the year 2000 gave predictions that we'd all be flying around
on wings and machines would meet directly transmitting knowledge into our brains
and things like that.
Ask a caveman what he thinks of the year 2000 would be like how humanity would
have progressed as it evolves and he probably wouldn't give you the right
answer.
That's a fair criticism,
but I would go even deeper than that because it's even more widely assumed that
aliens advance and evolve at a gradual rate similar to the rate of development
that we have thus far experience.
I don't think that even that is true.
That's where I differ with common belief.
I've talked about this as a central point in the video.
We are the last humans.
In that video I discuss the predicted course of genetic engineering and beyond
that artificial intelligence,
humans,
I caution in that video are on the verge of not only taking our evolution into
our own hands with the field of genetics,
but more crucially are on the verge of creating intelligent machines which can
improve themselves over generations become smarter and smarter and smarter until
suddenly someone builds computers as smart as humans capable of improving
themselves with no known limits.
Beyond that,
I didn't bother to examine the dynamic of robot apocalypse in that video.
I don't really care too.
It was beside the point I was trying to make.
The point I was trying to make was human civilization has progressed in terms of
discovering new science technology,
reforming our society at the pace it has because of the speed of the human
brain,
for lack of a better term,
the geniuses among us people we consider not only to think faster and more
broadly,
but in fact differently from the average sometimes take aspects of our
development into their own hands and speed of development up.
What we are on the brink of doing with artificial intelligence is constructing a
mortal geniuses without the drawbacks of our biological brains who may advance
far beyond human intellect.
There may be a limit to how smart AI could be.
No one really knows,
but there's no reason to think it's within a human limitation.
Certainly they will not think like humans though either way,
what happens after we create a super computer of that magnitude?
Who knows?
At some point we may have machines giving us the instruction is to eliminate
death to travel interstellar space.
The most ideal way to organize our society beyond that,
far beyond that even laying out would have taken thousands of years without
enhanced helped and just a matter of years.
This isn't something for the far off future.
I believe it's something which will happen within the next few hundred years.
Hence,
you know the provocative title.
We are the last humans.
It won't really help to make it illegal.
Someone in some underground layer,
we'll do it if the officials are forbidden from doing it.
The only alternative to such an event is a global pledge to live somewhat like
the Amish.
I can't say how many people will follow through with that.
It's impossible to say what happens after we develop a kind of technology.
Why is this relevant?
Well,
for obvious reasons,
I believe all civilizations which follow a pattern remotely similar to ours
eventually reached this point of having ultimate knowledge placed in front of
them from the fruits of their technology and progress.
Perhaps it's too tempting for them to resist and considering this development
takes place within a few hundred years of their ability to broadcast messages in
this space.
Theoretically anyway,
they may only be detectable for a very short span of time before they shoot and
evolve into something unrecognizable,
possibly combining their own minds with their advanced artificial intelligence,
achieving a completely new level of existence.
Definitely not conforming to expectations and probably not very interested in
us.
This may be the point which exit shows are waiting for us to reach before they
initiate contact.
Plus they may have evolved into something so complex that they're uninterested
in contact altogether.
Something which we don't quite understand yet.
I won't make predictions as to what this might be like.
That may very well be worse than a caveman predicting a year,
2017 but I will say that with our current model,
we predict alien civilizations to develop something like Dyson spheres,
which are basically super advanced structures which surrounds star together as
entire energy output and things like that.
But Scientific American published an article in 2015 called aliens.
Super Civilizations Absent from 100,000 nearby galaxies.
We've looked for Dyson spheres.
We didn't find them.
We've been listening for radio broadcast for 70 years or so.
We've heard nothing.
Our messages have been out in space for almost a hundred years.
No response.
The theory is worth considering.
It's somewhat relates back to the theory that aliens destroy themselves once
they reach our level of civilization and a little events around the level of
where they would be on the Carter shut scale at a type one civilization.
I don't believe that destroy themselves.
Though.
On the contrary,
I believe they take off into an incredible development in an unrecognizable and
unpredictable manner.
So it is in this model that we are forced to conclude that we may not meet
extraterrestrial civilization before we reached this point of development
ourselves.
The majority are frankly at or level below us or in all likelihood aware of us
and intentionally not communicating with us.
We may of course find extraterrestrial life within that time span.
It might be within our own backyard on Mars or Europa or something like that,
but as unfortunate as it sounds,
we may never talk to aliens until we are on an on a very advanced level already
unless we happen upon a very chance and find a civilization at or level or
catching up to us within 10 or 20 light years.
Therefore,
the most important answered the question,
what will aliens be like?
I'll be it.
A bit of a depressing answer for those of us who were hoping for a slow Sci-fi
development is a sort of bio robotic race of gods,
which in the end might be probably the best decision that such as civilization
could make and pretty cool.
It's depressing because we humans desire a challenge and a struggle to overcome
for ourselves.
We desire an exciting story.
Whenever we mentioned the prospect of alien life,
we expect our civilization to evolve gradually and face constantly new
adventures and struggles in ideas and concepts and things like that.
In reality though,
if this is indeed the chorus which extraterrestrial civilizations take and the
one that we are destined to take as well,
there will be no greater challenge and the one our species will face in dealing
with this technology wisely,
fairly and responsibly,
and no greater prospects for a good story than venturing into the complete
unknown and unpredictable.
So now let's go over the hypotheses I've laid out in this video.
We've established quite a bit for people who have never met anyone off our own
planet,
and it's worth considering that every hypothesis we've made could be wrong
either in a certain manner of speaking or just flat out entirely wrong.
However,
given our current understanding of our universe,
these hypotheses are in accordance with scientific information and what I
believe to be logical thought.
Here they are again listed numerically.
Number one,
intelligent extra terrestrials will likely require a star for energy.
Number two,
the sheer abundance as well as the biological effectiveness of carbon and water
throughout the university.
Just at the majority of intelligent I had.
Rush shows have similar chemical makeup to humans and evolve on similar rocky
worlds around their stars habitable zone number three,
the worlds from which intelligent beings originate likely have magnetic fields
comparable to the earth and accordingly play tectonics.
Number four their worlds are likely to have conditions,
would prevent mass extinctions from occurring too commonly such as nearby gas
giants and significant distance from volatiles.
Stars.
Number five intelligent exa treasures likely are or originated as carnivores or
omnivores who evolved in an environment which are turbulent and unpredictable
and therefore have an evolutionary pressure placed on them to evolve.
Intelligence.
Number six,
all life evolves and response to their environment and while they and their
environments maybe different similar structures and survival strategies such as
vision,
photosynthesis,
and multicellular life in general are prevalent throughout and how it had
worlds.
Traits which may be utilized in various environments and have evolved
independently numerous times on earth are the most likely to be found commonly
throughout the universe.
Furthermore,
the more like the environment of an extra planet is the earth,
the more similarly intelligent extraterrestrials may evolve in order to survive
within it.
Number seven,
intelligence extraterrestrials likely have some sort of social cooperation in
order to exchange ideas,
work for mutual benefit,
and safeguard their knowledge by communicating it to their offspring.
Each a requisite of what we consider civilization to reach it.
Civilization,
as we understand it,
the brains of these extra trash shows must be curious and Aveda and capable of
things such as generating abstractions.
Number eight,
intelligence.
Extraterrestrials may only develop civilization if they have the means to
manipulate the environment around them.
Having a brain geared toward creativity and innovation are as necessary as
developed civilization as a superficial biological structures required to do so,
such as precise,
manipulative digits.
Number nine,
intelligent extra shows may only develop civilization if the environment in
which they exist may be manipulated it thus excluding gas giants and
Panthalassic or ocean worlds.
Number 10 extraterrestrial civilizations which avoids self destruction and
follow even remotely similar path of technological and scientific development
that humanity has will eventually reach a point of capability at which they're
able to take not only their biology and evolution into their own hands,
but to build artificial intelligence capable of improving itself to reach points
far beyond those of its creators,
which the aliens may indeed utilize in its entirety.
Such technology would allow for rapid advancement beyond current human
understanding and because this development would occur not long after they have
developed a technology to communicate with other civilizations in the galaxy,
there may only be a period of a few hundred years in which civilizations are
capable of communication before they reach a point of rapid advancement.
Such advancement may very well lead to disinterest in civilization such as those
at a current level,
or at least a desire to not interfere with their progression until they reached
the same limit naturally.
And so that's all I have for you today.
Let me know what you think of all this in the comment section below and let me
know what kinds of things you might expect to see from aliens out there as well.
From what videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out.
Fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.